un classique du temps des fêtes qu'on va
peut-être vous proposer cette année
c'est le canapé de pâté de foie
alors nous allons en faire découvrir
trois aux gens ici présents dans le tout
nouveau magnifique complexe des sciences
de l'université de montréal où la
maîtrise de charcuterie we wept je
connais est ce que vous connaissez des
pâtés de foie de par oui parce que c'est
un genre de produit que je te disais
parfois l'occasion
oui mais la défaite attendue est juste
comme ça on me le gazon afin milieu le
petit fois c'est enfin je suis français
et nous on en mangeait donc
régulièrement tous les midis c'est
vraiment la culture de la charcuterie
après pour la période des fêtes on va
passer sur des mousse de foie gras des
choses comme ça c'est là c'est le foie
gras qui rentrent en valeur mais sinon
c'est plutôt au quotidien que l'on
commence de la mousse de foie de porc
mousse de foie de volaille c'est pas tes
deux fois parce que vous mangez
seulement ça va deux fois doit être
vraiment on doit le sentir c est ce
petit bout ferreux en fait qu'on a ce
qu'on recherche vous voyez c'est
vraiment donc le goût et la texture
ça va être vraiment ce qui est
primordial et bien sûr le la couleur
parce que en fait avant de porter à la
bouche avant de goûter sa passe par les
yeux ça passe par l'odorat le pâté faut
qu'ils aillent au minimum de 10%
part dans le cas qui nous occupe il
devient le pâté de foie c'est une mousse
on va plutôt parler de mousse parce que
c'est donc émulsionner au niveau du gras
d'un côté en fait on va cuire notre
grande peur de l'autre côté on va mettre
notre foi donc à marine et après on va
commencer par pulvériser notre gras et
on mélange tout ensemble on rajoute
nauséeux et on regarde la texture pour
voir si elle est bien dit
[Musique]
c'est déjà la consistance on voit qu'il
est d'accord mais je ne sais pas je
trouve un peu comme trop moi le nom j'ai
trouvé bon plus crémeux fois pour saluer
quoi bon aller aux fibres répandu du
blue sud-sud topo la viande sur la dame
moi je peux pas garder un virus des
textures texture lisse c'est vraiment
c'est ce qui est important
une texture deux fois en fait qu'est
granuleux 16 en bouche ça va vraiment
pas est agréable de savoir la couleur un
peu plus le blues avaient préféré le
biologique donc peu d'agents de
conservation 27 la jad qui changent la
couleur qui fait que le parc est devenu
plus grisâtre il faut savoir que le port
lem comprend une viande de porc donc cru
on la laisse à l'air libre au bout d'une
journée en fait à devient verte
c'est pas qu'il n'est pas bonne c'est
qu'est s'oxyde c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
c'est l'une des viandes ou en fait où il
ya le plus de nitrites qu'on l'utilisent
parce que visuellement en fait la
couleur n'est pas n'est pas belle
alors ici nous avons donc grade peur
foie de porc aux oignons moi ce que je
vois c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'émission
d'additifs qui sont trop proéminent
donc je pense que ça va être le produit
du breton qui va se rapprocher le plus
en termes de d'ingrédients de ce que je
produis mois pis le bleu vous avez
choisi celle du breton le belgique se
laisse un petit peu plus la viande par
contre définitivement le putsch du
détroit
jusqu'à présent trop salée ok c'est
l'éveil est quand même très salée ou à
aller vraiment plus à l'est j'ai
vraiment un peu plus de mal
c'est quoi le plus gradé guidera c'est
vraiment le genre 21 degrés les autres à
5,17 à sel sucre gras de porc bien sûr y
ait du nitrite alors le nitrite ça
permet en fait d'abord une oxydation
plus lente et bien sûr d'avoir une
conservation
[Musique]
encore blessée la mauricie trop salée
pour nous est que plus de lui parce que
vous avez choisi plaisir gastronomique
est ce qu on dit merci plaisirs
gastronomiques
je me vois lui un peu trop gros je
trouve
après le lot gras il faut du gras parce
que c'est le gras qui va aussi donner le
groupe
nous avons quasiment donc les mêmes
produits que dans les deux autres
eri torbat de césium et nitrite de
sodium les ritter bat ça va être pour la
couleur vraiment pour qu'on ait quelque
chose qui se rapproche vraiment du rouge
rosé contrairement à la couleur donc
sans et rieter battait sans nitrites qui
serait légèrement grisâtre au final ce
fut serré dans le monde du pâté de foie
quatorze personnes ont bien aimé ma vie
pas raté 17 du breton mais par deux voix
d'avancé plaisait gastronomique et
vainqueur aujourd'hui
merci à nos buteurs
[Musique]